more blood is on the hands of radical
district attorneys los angeles d.a
george gascon under fire after a career
criminal and known gang member he led
off the hook
slaughtered two lapd officers
harrowing security camera footage
capturing the moment these two cops were
ambushed while responding to a woman
being stabbed at a hotel
the suspect who died after a shootout
with police had a rap sheet about a mile
long his girlfriend accused him of
assault just a day before the shooting
he served two stints in prison and last
year was facing a third for possessing a
firearm as a felon that could have put
him behind bars for three years but
george gascon let him slide easy on the
last charge giving him a 20-day jail
sentence and put him on probation gascon
defending the move saying the slap on
the wrist was quote consistent with case
resolutions for this type of offense
given his criminal history
and the nature of the offense it's not
consistent judge this guy's like he's
beating his wife he's he's he's got an
illegal gun it's consistent with his
policies
which is it doesn't matter how violent
you are it doesn't matter what your
record it is it doesn't matter if you're
a threat to society we're going to let
you lose because we believe in racial
justice we don't give a damn about the
victims our job is to make sure that the
criminals get out you know what recall
is too good for this guy jesse recall is
not enough this guy should be prosecuted
i don't know what for but what he isn't
the blood of those police officers is on
his hands but for his handling the case
the way he did this dirtbag who's now
dead the gang member would have been in
prison and wouldn't have had the
opportunity to kill those cops
what we're seeing across this country
and with this administration is a
decision
by the people in power of what crimes
they want to prosecute and what crimes
they won't prosecute there is a real
segregation here and i'm not talking
color i'm talking about the right and
the left if they think that someone
should be forgiven for everything he's
done irrespective of the of the violence
that has has occurred to another
individual they don't care about it they
don't care that violence begets violence
there is a ripple effect every time one
human being injures another it's like
you toss a you toss a stone in a pond
and it just goes ripple to ripple to
ripple it just gets bigger and bigger
that's what's happening in our society
with these da's who have no right being
da's they should all be removed
immediately do you remember a couple
years ago when some of the nypd officers
turned their back on bill de blasio
you're probably pretty close to seeing
lapd officers doing something similar
taking a stand against the d.a out there
yeah i mean it's all about kind of the
contract you have with government or
society how can victims families not be
able to sue the city you pay taxes
what's the taxes for that's the
relationship you make with the
government i mean what if you don't
uphold your deal and you don't pay taxes
you're going to go to jail longer than
20 days yeah but what if they don't
uphold their side of the deal you could
get shot you can get killed not perfect
not providing safety and security there
needs to be some kind of consequences
for gascone because the people who make
these decisions get away with it no he's
not going to get shot by a gang banger
he doesn't live in the neighborhood and
hell that guy probably has his face his
name tattooed on his face you know so
he'll never run into the violence that
he unleashes it would be nice maybe to
force these da's to live in the
neighborhoods where they release these
guys so they can play play a role in gas
cones catch and release fantasies this
is no wonder though the networks are
running on january 6 because you have
two vital interests right now crime and
economy
the dems are lost on both that's why
they're using january 6 right now he
said what they're trying to say is sure
you're getting murdered you're baiting
there's no baby formula the cops are
getting killed but democracy's in peril
and if they're not watching it on the
networks because not everybody watches
network tv they're definitely seeing
this on the local news right in los
angeles and philly and new york they
lead with crime all the time yeah it is
the a number one story like you know the
first 10 minutes of every local
broadcast is crime that's in denver
included my mom was just telling me that
i also wonder about where is aoc on
there's a war on women yeah
this woman who is dating the guy
she gets assaulted she has the courage
to call the cops on him and they do
nothing and as you know having started
the first domestic violence unit for a
d.a it's not easy for women to make
those calls and to them to be ignored
and if
to the ripple effect if it wasn't going
to be the cops it was probably going to
be her and she knew it and these women's
groups do nothing to help to protect
these guys and the das they ought to be
paying attention that because there's
you i would it would be interesting to
look and see how many of these
guys that are let off
come back to hurt their girlfriends or
their wives and it's like it's over and
over again or they kill the children um
the other thing i wanted to point out is
bill mollusion our reporter who is he's
at the border now but he's based in los
angeles he said that under gascon's
policies
he said when he came into office that
the office of the government the office
of the
the his office would pay for the funeral
expenses for anyone who was killed by a
cop
and that could include this guy
and
unless gascon comes out and says it's
not going to happen we had a woman on
today that's the she's leading the
effort to get the signatures to put
gascone's recall to in place they need
about a hundred thousand more signatures
i can't imagine that they wouldn't be
able to get them
so what do you think about the
conversation of consequences not just
recall you know people wanting more than
that kind of accountability do you think
there's
any option for people that want more
than just a recall here with this d.a
and people putting lives at stake i'm
glad glad to be back around the table
two things i'd say one to dana's point
that group first of all i hope gascon is
recalled uh you're elected to be a d.a
to prosecute and put people behind bars
who commit violent acts not to coddle
them uh i think voters in los angeles
have a vested interest in this guy uh in
in in los angeles so we won't go through
it but i i hope that if this is what
voters want and we see this from the
outside here in new york i hope that's
what voters get to dana's point they say
they have 650 000 signatures they need
567 000 and i think they're aiming for
even more because they think some may be
invalidated as they go through this
signature verification process
voters around the country i don't view
this as a racial issue at all i think
this is just a fundamental american
issue
you can't go to work you can't go to
church you can't go to school you don't
feel confident dropping people off to do
those things if you don't have a
fundamental
understanding and
confidence that people are going to be
secure i don't care if the crime is
being committed by whatever racial group
could be white black hispanic asian
whatever may be if you get if you get
shot or you're mugged or you're harmed
or your kid you get a call you don't ask
was it a black person was it a white
person was an hispanic person if someone
calls from my child's school or my
children's school and said something is
wrong i'm going to rush to my child i
want to know if indeed there's someone
there to protect them so the biggest
thing that's happened in the last few
weeks is the recall of this san
francisco prosecutor the message to
democrats republicans and anyone that is
not serious about prosecuting criminals
if you want a job in public life
prosecuting criminals you know what you
should do jesse you should prosecute
criminals that's right you should put
them behind bars and you should not let
them out if they have a propensity to
engage in violent acts well period the
first recall against gascon failed yeah
okay so they're doing it the second time
hopefully they learn from chess and
boudin and they're trying with krasner
again but he just got re-elected with
like 70 of the vote it would help if the
president of the united states would
actually address these radical das and
tell him to knock it off but
he hasn't done that yet
up next a radical abortion group
declares open season on pro-lifers while
president biden and democrats do nothing
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now